nevertheless this is a very lucrative
industry for companies that sell
medicinal mushrooms with all kinds of
claims about their
effects uh that their efficacy in
treating
uh conditions that are very um sort of
mild conditions but also even
life-threatening
diseases terminal illnesses it's it's
just it's an area of
I suppose we call it mycology but it
drives me drives me crazy because I
don't like to see mushrooms and mushroom
signs misrepresented in this this way
these magic mushrooms have escaped their
counter-cultural Association and there
are many voices that suggest that they
these compounds should be used as a part
of mainstream medicine for treating
conditions like so hello and welcome to
the cheeky science show where in this
video I spoke with Nick money professor
of biology and Western program director
at Miami University in Oxford Ohio
referring to himself as the Mycologist
Nick is indeed an expert on mycology and
has authored a number of books that
celebrate the diversity of the microbial
world
in this research at Miami he has
pioneered the use of high-speed video
microscopy to understand the explosive
mechanisms used by fungi to launch their
spores into the air in this discussion
we discuss what fungi are whether they
are intelligent and how compounds formed
within mushrooms could affect our health
and our brain hope you enjoy
so hi Nick thank you for joining me
today and welcome to the cheeky science
show it's my pleasure thanks for
inviting me thank you and so the reason
I brought you one is because I recently
was reading your book mushroom and so
besides being an academic you've also
written many books which have helped to
educate on a variety of interesting
topics in particularly your area of
research which is mushrooms and fungi
and so
um to take a quote from your book you
describe a mushrooms that's been the
most wondrous invention of the last
billions of years of evolutionary
history on Earth and so I think most
people probably know what mushrooms are
but what A fungi how would you describe
them
yeah I mean they are the most brilliant
of evolutionary inventions
um just because they they Eclipse us
humanity and in in so many ways in terms
of their their beauty I'm not a big fan
of homo sapiens so but I do love
the fun joy what was the question so
what what are the fungi yeah what
exactly are they what are their defining
characteristics defining characters so
so the fungi represent as as we classify
them as a separate Kingdom of organisms
in a vast and diverse
uh group of eukaryotes so their cells
are constructed
uh like ours complicated cells with with
nuclei
um and in fact
fungi and animals are regarded as sister
groupings of of eukaryotes so we are
humans other animals are more closely
related to fungi than they are to plants
and the other great chunks of of
biological diversity
[Music]
um
what are they
so they they feed by absorption they
either grow in the form of filaments
that we call hyphy and so hyphy
penetrate their their food
materials and they Branch to form
colonies that we call Mycelia
and so that's the the vegetative part of
the the life cycle of these filamentous
fungi but fungi also grow in the form of
of budding yeasts
and they tend to form
they tend to grow as yeasts or rather
fungi that our yeasts tend to grow in
more fluid environments and then they
absorb food from their the surrounding
fluid environment so so that describes a
base their their
cellular form or morphology filament soy
or yeasts
but then using those
sort of Elementary cellular forms
they've Diversified into an
extraordinary group of organisms some of
which or or you know a few tens of
thousands of species for mushrooms fruit
bodies that are macroscopic
um
but the majority of the fungi are
microscopic and many of them we only
really know that they exist from the
their genetic Footprints we really know
nothing about the way that they look and
very little about the way that they they
grow so there's this sort of vast
invisible diversity of the fungi
yeah that we know from their their
genetics but we don't know much about
them so
um what else we refer to microscopic
fungi that don't form mushrooms or many
of them we refer to them as molds
and so they're everywhere mold spores
are in in every breath we take
there are vast numbers of these Mega
tonnages of these spores in the
atmosphere
so I find that particularly interesting
that it's a kingdom of organisms
with which we interact every moment of
our lives but for not for the most part
we're unaware of their existence and
then we might talk about this later but
the human body is is home to
um
Glory of fungal diversity there are
fungi that grow on the skin surface
they're A fungi that grow in our
reproductive tracts they're A fungi that
proliferate in the guts all of our the
passages of our respiratory system so
um I love that feature of the fungi that
they're that they're they're amazingly
diverse
and yet they're unseen for the most part
other than mushrooms and
yeah that's what I said and the thing is
so what fascinates me most is how we're
more similar to the mushrooms and like
mushrooms outer plants and so I was just
wondering like what got you fascinated
about mushrooms and what kind of uh
features of mushrooms have you mainly
been researching yeah I mean it was
um I'm a product of affirmative action I
went to a large comprehensive school as
a teenager in in Britain in Oxfordshire
but I got into a great University I was
an undergraduate at Bristol
[Music]
um and one of the first lectures that
that we had in biology was was given by
this Mycologist a lovely man called
lovely Professor called Mike Madeline I
really knew nothing about fungi before
that lecture and afterwards it's like I
was completely hooked I had no idea that
these amazing organisms exist and and he
presented them in such such an
attractive fashion so that that was my
my beginning
um and uh back in when was I 1980 I went
to University so I just turned 60 last
year I forgotten what your question is
now was this a Folsom autobiography it
was great um I was asking yeah what were
you interested in mushrooms which you
kind of answers and then what kind of
errors are using I said yeah
so I I've
most of my work has really been I've
done some biochemical work on on fungi
most of my work though has really been
on on biomechanics the biomechanics of
the fungi so most of my peers have
really studied
um
phylogenetic relationships among the
fungi so the evolutionary history of the
fungi using you know genetic techniques
I'd be much more interested throughout
my career in the mechanics of these
these organisms so the way I mentioned
fungal filaments these hyphy the way
that they actually push their way into
solid materials is is fascinating plus
the biochemistry of that that that that
invasive process
um I've also worked with students for
many years looking at the way that
spores are discharged into the air so
I've said that there's vast numbers of
these spores in the air it's really
interesting that we don't know how those
whole classes of those Sports we don't
know how they become airborne so the the
the mechanisms have not been solved at
that
sort of uh uh at that level of cellular
biomechanics so I find that really
interesting
so um most of the research that I've
done really is in those areas of sort of
of growth the biomechanics of growth and
reproduction
um
among the fungi so it's sort of an
esoteric field within an already
esoteric field but some somebody uh
somebody has to do it well that's what
I've done in my career but my interests
are much broader than that I'm
interested in human interactions with
fungi I'm interested in the human
microbiome
uh I'm interested in fungal genetics and
I've become really interested in fungal
Evolution recently and thinking about
that from
um from a mechanical perspective also
but really getting into some of the
molecular phylogenetic literature that I
probably avoided when I was when I was
younger but
yeah I suppose my interests of have
broadened as I've
uh entered early middle
oh cool how do you actually go about
studying them in the research lab and
how do you what sort of experiments are
you really sort of doing
well some of the uh some of the
experiments that I've published and
published with students and this this is
a few years ago really that have
attracted the most interest and I keep
keep getting you know correspondence on
this work is is looking at these fast
mechanisms of Spore discharge the way
that spores are shot into the air
and I think I was fortunate in my timing
about getting interested in this because
the technology of high-speed video
became available sort of in the early
part of this Century or rather became
cost effective
in the early 2000s after 2010 really
and this enabled researchers including
myself and collaborators to look at
these for the first time to actually see
these fast movements
under the microscope I mean before then
there have been beautiful studies
published by investigators on
The Liberation of spores
and and these were these were very
clever investigators in the sense that
most of their work was based upon
inference because you could never
actually see these spores moving through
through the air because they were moving
at such a vast clip over such a short
distance
but they they performed really gorgeous
experiments to to figure out how things
worked and and so when these high-speed
cameras became available we could
actually for the first time see these
movements and for somebody as obsessed
as myself
um this was it was really exciting just
to see
for the first time the first time
anybody at these seen these things fly
through the air using cameras running up
to you know a million frames a second
so that was just in terms of pure pure
drama in the lab which is a fairly
fairly you know rare occurrence for for
all scientists but that that that that
takes some beating
um and then other experiments too going
back to when I first came to the states
in the 1980s
we were interested then or I was working
in in a lab that was interested in
in the movement of ions across the cell
membranes of
fungi so uh
iron selective channels
um and then also
fungi pump protons charge hydrogen atoms
across their membranes they acidify
their surroundings and so that was part
of what we studied and
that was interesting also from a
from a what
it was interesting from a manipulative
perspective because we were using uh
intracellular electrodes
that that are sort of more familiar to
people that do electrophysiological
experiments on on nerve cells
um but we were using these to penetrate
fungal cells and measure those iron
currents and
voltage differences across membranes
so those are some of the experiments
that um I've been involved with
across the Great eons of time I mean
I've also done
I've just I've just been working on a
review article on on some some
aspects of mushroom development and um
um I looked back I'm not going to say um
again in this whole interview
I can edit that myself
um I just did um I took students into
the woods Woods which sounds really
creepy but I went with you know I had
some of my classes of of undergraduate
researchers and we we did work in forest
ecosystems actually doing things like
measuring the temperature of of
mushrooms of fruit bodies and that was
fascinating
so um so experiments both at the level
of individual microscopic cells and then
also on whole fruit bodies in
in Woodland ecosystems
yeah I'm probably missing out some
things there but
sorry we might come back to them um
because you mentioned that you have
interest in The evolutionary history of
mushrooms um and so you'll see one thing
that's um a resin multiple times is
relationships materialistic
relationships with different plants
termites bees and so just wondering like
um you also had a review recently about
fungal intelligence describing whether
they have Consciousness
um able to make the decisions and just
wondering if you could elaborate on some
of your thoughts about the intelligence
of fungi
yeah so there's a sort of very
we walk a knife edge I think in or
mycologists that are serious scientists
walk along a knife edge where or I do
anyway
seeking to popularize the biology of the
fungi
without getting to woo-woo and there's
so much Fantastical and and uh crazy
thinking about about the fungi and and
that's that's not me I'm sort of the
contrarian Mycologist
then we could talk more about that but
with this essay that I wrote about
fungal consciousness
that was stimulated by the fact that
there have been some beautiful
experiments performed by not by me but
by other fungal biologists looking at
the Exquisite sensitivity of fungal
cells and their responsiveness to
environmental cues
and these
to me some of them
reach the level of reach the level of
what that they were suggestive of fungal
memory
and so I thought that given
well given actually the sloppiness of
the definition of Consciousness it
seemed important for somebody to
actually position the fungi within that
discussion about the ubiquity of
Consciousness or at least sensitivity
throughout the the living world
and there have been there's been quite a
lot of work on slime molds which are not
fungi and the way they show
evidence of of at least short-term
memory in finding food sources well we
see similar activity similar
responsiveness among the fungi
and so I wrote that essay to to pull
together some of these lines of evidence
and begin to say well yeah depending
upon our definition of consciousness
I think it's sensible to actually
suggest that fungi might
possess
that attribute
but it comes down to down to the what do
we mean by Consciousness and it's we we
so privilege the human version of
Consciousness and and for always really
or until very recently we've we've
removed the rest of life from that
uh
what level of respect so we do we you
know if if we go part of the Cartesian
views of
of
intelligence and Consciousness I mean
Descartes thought that you know only
humans were
were really equipped with
Consciousness they were the only
conscious organisms and the argument in
discourse on reason begins really with
the fact that we're the only organisms
with
language or at least the language that
Descartes could understand and uh so he
excluded the rest of life but we really
we we managed to sustain that view of of
nature for centuries until I think
relatively recently and so now we
recognize that
animals other animals are conscious at
least those with brains but there's no
real clear dividing line between
something that we would regard as
conscious and something that is
unconsciousness it comes down to
sensitivity to one's surroundings
responsiveness and if we use that kind
of
language we we start to see that
Consciousness is something that is found
throughout nature
yeah I think you're right I think it's
yeah the fact that this nuclear way of
defining Consciousness at the moment is
hard to
um describe it and I like have the
proper discussion I mean because I've
had different definitions and one way is
to sort of categorize Consciousness
Consciousness to different levels
um with like humans being on the highest
level but yeah I think it's interesting
to think about it and so what could you
elaborate more on the experiments that
they did to sort of test the
intelligence of the funky
so
um some of the most interesting
experiments so they're done on these
fungi that in nature they engage in Wood
decomposition so they feed on
cellulosic biomass would
lignocellulosic biomass they feed on
wood
um and so in the lab you can actually
grow these on culture
um plates and you can feed them with
little wood blocks and it takes a while
for them them to grow but some of the
most interesting experiments have shown
that
if you provide a colony with a with a
wood block
so I should should say so a fungus then
can germinate from a single Spore to
produce a circular colony
and they span out in all directions
equally until they find a food resource
a food a wood block
and then what happens is that the colony
changes its Behavior changes its growth
pattern to sort of privilege that area
of the of its environment
so more cells are actually recruited
more of these filaments are recruited to
grow toward that
block of food and then food is actually
distributed around throughout the colony
from that
block of wood as it begins to be
decomposed which is really interesting
biochemical process in itself and really
quite mysterious in some ways
but some I I digress
um when you take that so once the colon
is growing on the wood block you can
take that that wood block and put it on
another
plate
and once it's actually exhausted the
resources in that would block what's
interesting is it tends to grow out from
the same side of the wood block sort of
in the perceived direction of where it
found food the
um found food the last time just got
kind of spatial memory I mean I think I
think that's amazing uh and uh so that's
that's one indication of this this
sensitivity that's that might be
appended with the term
Consciousness you see this at the level
of single cells I mentioned experiments
in which we were penetrating
fungal hyphae with
microelectrodes and
they are being anthropomorphic here but
they don't like being stabbed with
little glass needles and so you see all
these physical responses to the the to
the disturbance of the cell
two again showing this this
great sensitivity responsiveness to to
the environment and the way that fungi
grow that we can present
fungal colonies with mazes and they will
negotiate those mazes they will change
their growth form and grow over ridges
it's
these are all examples of the complexity
of the fungi and those will be examples
that I'd bring to bear to say yeah we've
got some
primitive I suppose form of of
consciousness
but I think you can do an experiment in
similar experiments I mean some of the
most Exquisite work really on on
cellular
sensitivity and Consciousness was
performed a lot of it in the early part
of the 20th century on on amoebas on
actually on Amoeba proteus and other
species of amoeba it's really really
interesting showing them actually
chasing their prey and reacting to
negative stimuli it's fascinating work I
think
yeah I've seen that video a couple of
times there's something I've played in
the undergrad lectures and but speaking
of the hyphy um so that's the individual
cell and those cells can come together
to form them like um the mycelium and so
is that just one individual like how do
you go about defining an individual
within
um the fungus and like is yeah I maybe
it's just my misunderstanding no I mean
that's a great that's a great question
and the the issue of fungal
individuality is really really
complicated so
um there's there's a there are some
famous fungal colonies or Mycelia that
cover vast areas many hectares in the
United States and elsewhere
um that have gotten or some years ago
then got a lot of media attention
because they're so big and there was the
claim that this might be the world's
largest some of these things might be
the world's largest organisms outweigh
the biomass of a blue whale
Etc
um
your question's a good one though so a
fungus A mycelium that spreads over some
vast area of forest is this an
individual well different parts of the
colony are reacting to different food
resources in different ways they're
feeding in different locations so there
is some degree of
of
autonomy within within the colony
and also if we look at the genetics of
these colonies
in some cases their chimeric so they're
they're genetics differ from position to
position so does that suggest that we're
dealing with a single individual or a
population of
fungi it's really complicated because we
can get genetic differences even among
colonies that are connected physically
or this there's a fluid continuity
between this this large Mycelia and
Mycelia can actually merge they can they
can interconnect and so you've got
um
two or more individuals that are
actually part of this larger Colony so
it's a difficult thing how do how do we
how do we Define
um an individual well I suppose these
questions really relate and not maybe on
a sort of more philosophical level
throughout nature
I mean the more that we understand about
the human body and the
Galaxy of microorganisms within the gut
and then on the skin and Elsewhere on on
the body
I mean yeah we're walking ecosystems
rather than perhaps individuals
I find that interesting and similar
questions do apply to the fungi
you're playing
um and so besides like
um Baker's use which actually I've used
in the labs and stuff before they're
obviously very easy to like genetically
modify these other fungal species that
produce mushrooms Etc how amenable are
they to like genetic manipulation
um to do some of these sort of
Investigations yeah that's that's a
great question because it is difficult
and yeast has dominated so saccharomyces
cerevisiae was dominated
well eukaryote genetics well that may
not be true more than humans I mean
they're far more important than us but I
mean they've been a model system in
eukaryote genetics eukaryotic genetics
for for many decades so there are
filamentous fungi that are also very
amenable to genetic transformation so
there's a fungus called neurospera
crassa that that's a very important
system and in fact it was investigated
by
um sort of early
molecular geneticists sort of before
yeast actually so it was sort of the
first model system
in genetics that was was a fungus
um and there are other filamentous fungi
that that are amenable to to genetic
transformation
the mushroom forming fungi are quite
problematic but there are a few there's
a model model system so it's called
copranopsis
that's that's studied in in um
with increasing Brilliance I think by
the the geneticists that actually work
on copernopsis
this is important because
in terms of structural complexity if
you've got something that forms a
mushroom this is
patently more
um it's it's it's a it's a more
difficult lift than than being a yeast
and yet we don't understand much about
the genetics of mushroom formation and
so having a model system like
copernopsis is really really important
if we're going to begin to understand
the development of these
uh the the multicellular development of
the fungi and that's been something
that's that's been lagging for a long
long time but I think more of my younger
peers are beginning to recognize this
and so I I think that that's one of the
most exciting areas of research now is
these sort of
evodivo studies on the fungi
that have been been performed on yeast
for a long long time but taking that to
the level of fungus that produces
produces a large macroscopic fruit body
I I find that stuff really really
interesting
yeah likewise because as I was somewhat
preparing for the sense for you I was
trying to find like the sort of latest
areas of research and I guess another
question then is where are like the hubs
of research into mushrooms and fungal uh
funky at the moment
yeah so the the work on mushroom
development there's a few Labs that work
on this and I find that
really fascinating
the other
probably or the the more significant
area of research on fungi in terms of
of in terms of what in terms of funding
priorities would be the study of
pathogenic fungi those that in fact
humans being of particular concern but
also the study of fungi that in fact
plants and crop plants in particular I
mean it's always about us we're exactly
you know such narcissists so we'll study
the fungi that are important for human
health and economic activity or survival
I understand the reasons for this but so
those are the areas so yeah working
medical mycology is is fascinating and
uh it certainly an is an area of
priority
work on fungal pathogens of of
plants but then these other areas I mean
this sort of it's It's a niche area you
know evolutionary development of of
mushrooms but I find it exciting
and well since you brought up about the
interactions between fungi and humans
um obviously one thing I've always found
fascinating and I've spoken about
multiple times on my channel is the gut
microphone and I always talk about
bacteria and I always failed to mention
um the attributes to fungi that are also
living within us and on us and so
um how many of them are pathogenic or
like how what what is the beneficial
contributions of funky to human health
yeah so that's that's a great question
so some of the fun joy that we find in
in the gut for example in a healthy gut
can become problematic on the conditions
where our our immune system is
debilitated or we suffer some form of
physical injury so the fungi that tend
to cause many of the fungi that cause
problems in in human health are
opportunistic
uh pathogens
so they become
life-threatening they can form
life-threatening infections when we're
we're when we're damaged when we're
compromised in some some way as I say
either through immune damage or through
some physical damage like a severe burn
um
so we could talk about some of the fungi
the the fungi that cause human
infections but in terms of the positive
effects of the fungi on human health so
those come in a number of different
forms one is that fungi interact with
bacteria and other microorganisms in the
gut and elsewhere and
uh
establish what a sort of a a workable
microbial ecosystem within a place like
like the gut where things work in
balance and we don't see an overgrowth
of one particular kind of microorganism
and so that's that's part of it is in
terms of their interactions with
bacteria and actually supporting what we
what we regard as a healthy ecosystem
um on the skin surface we find fungi
that are very important in appear to be
very important in in skin Health fungi
really are found on every scrap of the
skin surface
but there's a lot of interest in fungi
yeasts that grow on the scalp and
actually consume the sebum so some of
the the waxy secretions on the scalp and
this these appear to be a part of a
healthy
what microbiome on the on the skin
surface
the the way that they're actually
operating there is in many cases this is
emerging science but it could be through
again by controlling the the growth of
bacteria
producing antibacterial compounds I
guess we'd regard them as we call them
antibiotics
um in that location but also doing
things like
degrading
um
uh skin cells as they're Shed from from
the the skin surface and actually
decomposing those skin cells this waste
material
having effects upon the pH of the skin
so there's probably a lot more effects
of these fungi on the skin surface than
we we recognize some of them are
deleterious
but also these are a natural part of the
human
ecosystem so
yeah that's interesting things I
definitely agree that this under
explored at the moment but just maybe
think that'll say there's always these
talks about probiotics and
um beneficial
um like foods you should eat that would
support your bacterial growth the good
bacteria in the guts but I suppose maybe
there'll be ways of trying to enhance
your fungal microbiome or something at
some point
there are there are actually
um
so there is at least one one probiotic
that seems to have I mean with sort of
decent
um supporting evidence that this is
useful for in gut health particularly
for somebody that suffers from
food poisoning for example when they
travel and they suffer from very severe
diarrhea there's a there's a probiotic
yeast strain that seems to be really
effective in seems to be somewhat
effective in resetting gut health and
allowing the the natural
supportive gut microbiome to to reboot
and so yeah that's definitely an area of
active research that I suspect is going
to grow grow in the future
but it's it's also an area of
of medicine that sort of buyer beware
because there are a lot of claims made
for products that of no
sort of
demonstrated efficacy well speaking of
healthcare then
um like obviously a lot of us eat
mushrooms what is like the just general
nutritious nutritional value of mushroom
consumption got the mushrooms have no
nutritional value whatsoever
so let me
if we're looking for a source of
calories mushrooms are a really really
poor source of calories they might that
they're I mean they've got a hydro
skeleton because the mushrooms are
formed from hundreds of thousands or
millions of hyphy and they get pumped up
with water they generate pressure and
that's how the mushroom
emerges
but in terms of that calorific value
they're very very low so they're
actually they're good for one's diet if
you want to actually reduce
um consumption of
energy of calories
um
they contain traces of of useful
nutrients but nothing that you wouldn't
get through other components of your
your diet so they're very low in in
soluble sugars
they are a source of what what's their
use in in diet they're a source of
soluble and insoluble fiber so that's a
good part of your diet I mean most of
the reason that I think we we enjoy
mushrooms is that they add texture to to
our food but we're not eating them
because of their sort of inherent
uh certainly in terms of their
nutritional
value
there may be exceptions to this but
there these are unproven at this point
so there's a huge amount of interest in
the
the the
medicinal or health promoting effects of
different mushrooms in the diet
but I regard most of those studies as
being
um what
suspect I wanna I wanna show me the
evidence show me more evidence that
these really have a positive effect upon
human health there's a lot of wishful
thinking that that goes on in that that
area so I'm not talking about mushrooms
that are s the the mushroom extracts
that are sold as medicinal supplements
but in terms of mushrooms in the diet
yeah they can be a useful part of the
diet they certainly make our diet more
the food that we eat more interesting
they have some of them have interesting
flavors
um
I'm not sure if I answered your question
there but yeah
worry for calorie in fact fact
interestingly you can you can look this
up I mean it's like lettuce
so if you're starving lettuce isn't
going to keep you going it's it's you'd
have to eat an awful lot of lettuce
unless you're a
a manatee or something like that and
then indeed you do eat enormous amounts
of
plants with relatively low
caloric value but
um
yeah yeah one of the questions I was
going to ask and you sort of already
touched upon it was um from reading your
book you had a sort of um like a more of
a negative opinion on some of the health
claims that are made regarding
um some specific species of of mushrooms
and so I was going to ask if your fees
have changed since like the 10 10 or so
years since the book was first published
um you've read the mushroom mushroom
mushroom I've written so many books so
yeah I also published a an article in
2015 that was titled our mushrooms
medicinal question mark that reviewed a
lot of the literature on medicinal
mushrooms and found it lacking and now
what are we eight years later I haven't
changed my opinion
at all and in terms of placebo control
double-blinded clinical trials on on the
effects of mushrooms the evidence is
lacking
nevertheless this is a very lucrative
industry for companies that sell
medicinal mushrooms with all kinds of
claims about their
effects uh that their efficacy in
treating
uh conditions that are very um sort of
mild conditions but also even
life-threatening
diseases terminal illnesses it's it's
just it's an area of
I suppose we call it mycology but it
drives me drives me crazy because I
don't like to see mushrooms and mushroom
signs misrepresented in this this way
there are some areas of research though
on medicinal mushrooms that are more
promising one of those is so there's a
mushroom called
lion's mane
that produces
a number of compounds that have been
studied
so isolated and studied in their
purified form most of the work's been
done on tissue cultured cells neurites
nerve cells and so these compounds seem
to promote the
the growth and the proliferation of
nerve cells in culture there have been
some experiments on
lab
rodents also with these these
compounds from Lions mean that maybe
show some interesting effects upon the
nervous system
and so it is it's plausible that there
are compounds present in mushrooms that
have
remarkable pharmacological effects but
all I've pushed for
in my writing is for some serious
science to be done but as I say this is
being done on some of these compounds
from lion's mane
there are also compounds called beta
glucans that are present in pretty much
all well in all fungal cell walls
those may have some interesting effects
those those compounds do have some
interesting effects upon the immune
system and so in terms of the immune
reactions within the gut
so that they clearly actually stimulate
an immune response
but whether these can be whether these
effects can be captured in the form of a
drug that might have
you know real medicinal
uses I think we're some way away from
that so that's really what I'm would
have
you know but that's what I'm saying is
that we just need more research on these
compounds and at the moment it's a case
of Bio beware and the claims that are
made for
miracle cures are just they're just
beyond all bounds of
of plausibility but
it's not surprising is it I mean when
people are diagnosed with conditions
that don't respond well to you know
prescription drugs that we get from our
physicians it's not surprising that
they're looking for other
approaches to treating ailments I mean
we we've always done this
but um but mushrooms should be mushrooms
are promising in a medicinal
sense I think because if we look at
mushrooms in the woods
where they're surrounded by
microorganisms of all kinds there are
nematodes soil nematodes there are
insects that
um deposit their eggs in mushrooms and
so forth and yeah mushrooms survive for
days
in these beautiful forms and released
their spores very effectively they must
be producing an incredible array of
biologically active compounds
that affect the physiology of
microorganisms but also insects and
other invertebrates and so that leads me
to be more optimistic about the presence
of
medically useful compounds in mushrooms
it's just that we haven't identified
what these
compounds may may be
antibiotics we know of course that
the great antibiotics
isolated from
not mushroom forming fungi but the fungi
that we call ascoyce fungic relatives of
of yeast
but all fungi produce and probably
produce antibiotics in one form or
another and we just don't know a lot
about the
properties of these compounds there is
beautiful mushrooms called tiny things
called Birds Nest fungi
that produce little nests with uh fungal
eggs that are full of spores and they
get flicked into the air by raindrops
but the the bird's nest fungi produce an
amazing array of antibiotics that have
been studied by biochemists and uh
you know it's possible in the future
this might lead to the development of
new
families of antibiotics that could be
useful for treating
bacterial infections in US
well it's interesting um you mentioned
some of these points because as I was
somewhat like researching for this
discussion I think because of what I was
looking at I ended up getting a lot of
adverts for different Health Products
that like coffee and whatnot that have
different extracts from different
mushrooms in and so then I did look at
some of them like lion's mane and also
shiitake mushroom came up a lot and
Takis Town some of them have um the
claim seems to be attributed to these
glucons as you mentioned that seems to
somewhat be stimulating the immune
system but then I think you sort of
touched in the question which is is it
always such a good thing to be over
stimulating or activating immune cells
and so then I came across another study
where a guy had um I mean it's like an N
is one case study where he'd consumed a
lot of uh sitake mushrooms whilst in
Tokyo
um and he then had dermatitis on the
skin so the skin rash went after a
couple of days but
um I mean he knows if it was the
mushroom that caused it after
consumption but then when I was then
thinking about these um supplements or
these sort of powders that they're like
concentrated versions
as you know maybe one mushroom by itself
was okay but he like yeah I don't know
could you do you have any comments on
that yeah I mean it's it's the idea that
that stimulating the immune system is
yeah there's been actually quite a lot
written about this by immunologists
they're very skeptical but the idea of
sort of stimulating the immune I mean an
asthma attack is a is is a is a stimulus
is is generated by stimulus to the to
the immune system so it's not
necessarily a good thing to do to to to
to walk around hyper inflamed it's a
bizarre claim isn't it it's it it needs
some some thinking
um it needs some some uh further
thinking it's like the claims that are
made about antioxidants
I mean antioxidants in our in our diet
and and the way that if we eat foods
that are very high in antioxidants this
is something that's going to be be
beneficial
um maybe that's a a broader issue but
but the idea that uh
stimulate the immune system and and with
that we need to be eating
yeah even the definition of antioxidants
is is um pretty curious in in the hands
of some food manufacturers
but that has some sort of mushroom
I would be show me the evidence show me
the evidence
and so um besides something like the
health claims has also obviously been
some uh interest in understanding the
Psychedelic compounds that are also
found in mushrooms
um the the notable ones being
salicylbine which comes from one is it
one species or one family of The Silo B
I'm not sure how to pronounce actually
yes a psilocybin which is the is the
active
compound and then after after we ingest
psilocybin it's converted to silosine
that actually interacts with the
the nervous system but it's actually
produced by a few hundred species of
mushrooms
and it's interesting well anyway a few
hundred species of mushrooms and not all
of them are actually members of the same
type grouping and so whether the the
biochemical Pathway to generate
psilocybin has evolved more than once is
an interesting question
but yeah so it's a few hundred but the
the source for psilocybin
well the commercialized source for it is
really it's it's mainly one species
that's grown as the source of psilocybin
but tremendous interest in the
properties of this
there's alkaloid silosin yeah it's it's
it really is interesting so you I'm sure
you're aware there have been
there's been some extremely good
uh science done on psilocybin so it's
sort of these magic mushrooms have
escaped their counter-cultural
Association and there are many voices
that suggest that they these compounds
should be used as a part of mainstream
medicine for treating conditions like
um
PTSD so post-traumatic stress disorder
forms of clinical depression that don't
respond to Conventional antidepressants
and other conditions and as as Waters
mood elevators in
or people that have been diagnosed with
a terminal illness I mean they seem to
have these remarkable properties in in
making people
view their lives
differently and in many cases
reducing
the symptoms of chronic depression and
so forth it's an area of research that
requires a lot more investigation
also
um there is there is some bias in many
of these experiments
and there are certainly some patients
that react very negatively to
to these to these compounds but this is
something that should be studied further
in my view and then there are a number
of states in
the United States where the use of these
mushrooms has been the use of
psilocybins being legalized at least
within clinics that are regulated by
by the states so yeah it's really
interesting and um
the
was a study published just a few weeks
ago about the action of
silosin which is which is interesting
that so it it mimics serotonin but
what's interesting about this compound
is it seems to actually be able to
penetrate the
penetrate nerve cells and actually
interact with
um
um interact with
serotonin receptors that actually exist
intracellularly which is really
interesting
so it's through this this further
through this process of of methylation
of the um
uh compound that enables it to get it
becomes more soluble excuse me it it it
penetrates cell membranes more easily
and then it's actually got these effects
inside cells and so this might be part
of the whole business about why the the
the perceived effects of these compounds
is so profound it's such a game changer
for people that
that use psilocybin that um it could be
that is actually entering the cells of
the nervous system it's not proven it's
I think it's mostly in vitro
to work on cells that have been cultured
cells but I know it's just another
interesting part of this
investigative journey and the fact that
we're looking at other scientists are
looking at the effects of
silosin on the left of the level of
individual cells and so forth is is
really really interesting yeah for sure
like I mean I
part of the mechanism then might be that
there's like
um vesicles forming within the cells and
they're getting transported to the
membrane and maybe
yeah I mean honestly I've not read the
paper and I'm speculating on potential
mechanisms but as well I guess the
conversion of individual differences of
um going from the salocybin to silacin
but then the body is going to be
different potentially between different
people
yeah yeah
getting back to philosophy it's
interesting though too that why is it
why is it in the human condition that so
many people
feel that their life in experiences
enhanced by
consuming this this material I suppose
it's the same thing with
other compounds that change our
the behavior of our nervous system to
change our moods but uh yeah it's
interesting and then well yeah then that
will see
also Western as to why are the mushrooms
making these come
get beneficial for the mushroom like uh
like the abundance in the mushrooms
suggests maybe it's doing something
interesting or I know more interesting
to me that much more interestingly
effectively effects on the human body
again because like present company
accepted I you know my view of humans is
pretty bleak but you know why why do
mushrooms because they've been producing
them for for around tens hundreds of
millions of years from these tens of
millions of years
um that's really interesting I mean the
prevailing view is that they were they
they evolved
to affect interactions between
the fungal fruit body the reproductive
organ and insects
but the evidence for this is still
pretty pretty limited but that seems to
be be the case and there's there's
experiments that suggest that psilocybin
has you know profound effects upon the
nervous system of of insects and so
that's probably it relates to the way
that mushrooms interact with insects
then the question is are mushrooms
trying to get you know ward off the
insects probably not and probably with
something that's affecting their nervous
system there's something about they want
to attract insects and there's something
about the way that it affects the
nervous system of the insect and in that
case why would a fungus want to attract
an insect well then it comes down to the
distribution of spores so mushroom
spores are dispersed by wind for insects
are important accessories as agents of
dispersal in carrying spores away from
mushrooms so that that may be where part
of the answer lies then it is is
actually an attracting insects to fruit
bodies through co-evolution yeah because
as you say I mean obviously they've been
doing this way before we existed or they
were like that's what I came across some
other theories about how human
intelligence potentially was enhanced by
I guess early
um hominids consuming uh mushrooms that
contain psychedelic compounds
um it's some sort of ethereal hypothesis
I'm not sure
it's the um it's referred to as the the
stoned ape hypothesis that's it yeah
it's
ridiculous absolutely there are they how
they suggest this I mean it's it's
obviously we don't have evidence for
this it is interesting how far people
will stretch
foreign
stretch credulity I mean there are there
are some interesting there are rock
paintings very ancient Rock paintings
um that appear to show mushrooms and
would I mean probably we have been
humans have been ingesting magic
mushrooms for a very low very long time
and and our our hominid relatives and
ancestors too so this is something
that's that's happened
but whether this is responsible for the
for the Brilliance of the human brain I
you know probably not probably not
supposed Brilliance of the human brain
um but besides the silence I've been
there's other like the flight agric
mushroom nap producers like slightly
different compounds right and so I guess
it comes back to the question of how
much unexplored potential compounds are
out there in different species
um yeah yeah I assuming that relates to
that and then the issue of these other I
mean yes absolutely so um compounds in
flyer Garrix that have different effects
upon the nervous system
um
that's right but it relates to this this
idea of all of these compounds within
mushrooms that were are designed
by natural selection to interact with
animal uh animal tissues and so yeah
yeah
a lot more work to be done a great area
for fungal biochemists I mean being a
bicy chemist I'm like naturally
intrigued by with these questions and
then like what genes are regulating and
whatnot but um yeah super super
fascinating and then just speaking about
um just like current research and funky
as well I saw some interesting video
about how
um fungi were able to sort of clear up
an oil spill and I was just curious if
you have any thoughts about other like
alternative applications of mushrooms
and fungi because I've also seen like
companies making like leather mimics out
of growing mushrooms yeah so the the
idea with oil spills and using fungi
um
to ameliorate the effects of of
pollution
um so this is an area it's referred to
as micro remediation or at least some
people call it micro remediation
fungi do produce such an amazing array
of enzymes that
can break down all kinds of chemical
compounds
and indeed many of the hydro
hydrocarbons that are produced by you
know oil and gas Industries there are
fungi that will break down these
compounds or parts of them whether or
not these can be used on a level it's
it's a matter of scale
so certainly in a lab experiment we can
show that these fungi
can uh
degrade and in some cases detoxify these
compounds but whether whether that can
be used on a scale to deal with an oil
spill
um I must admit I'm quite skeptical and
similarly there's interest in using
fungi
they have a cleansing effect upon
soils and a cleansing effect upon
groundwater but but and we see this in
in
forest ecosystems but whether we can use
these same fungi to actually
treat to remediate an area that's been
damaged by coal mining for it for
example again I think it's a matter of
scale and
um
I'm skeptical I mean I think I'm a
realist but there are certainly
companies that are that are looking at
this and hey wonderful if this can be
actually produced and commercialized but
um
it's it's I think in so many cases we're
guilty of wishful thinking that you you
know there's a paper that shows that
this particularly unpleasant
organic compound can be
biodegraded by a fungus but you know
it's it's a matter of scale
so evidently from our discussion
mushrooms have and we'll continue to
play an important role in
um and not just allies but the future of
the the planets and so
um just other areas of interest of mine
have been in terms of like future feeds
and how mushrooms seems to be able to
grown and lots of sort of waste products
and so what do you think are the major
um questions that need to be addressed
in the field of fungal biology that's
kind of a big question wow this is a big
question
um
I mentioned something earlier which is
interesting and it does relate to to
food production on so on
cellulose lignose cellulosic wastes
right you can grow mushrooms on those
materials
and so this is perhaps important for
recycling and in growing mushrooms that
could be you know
part of our diet
um the actual mechanisms that fungi use
so this is for you as a biochemist to
actually break down lignocellulose
uh is a lot of this is really quite
mysterious so they're they're A fungi
that a brown rot fungi
that are capable of they don't actually
break down the lignin polymers within
wood but they work around them and break
down the cellulose and the cellulose is
decomposed just to release glucose and
and that's how their metabolism is
fueled but the way that they can they
can extract or break down the
cellulose without actually having to
remove the lignin it's not not clear so
that's there's some really interesting
research in that area so just figuring
out some other fundamentals of the way
that decomposition works
that it's um that that's really excuse
me that's really fascinating to me
what else what else is interesting
there are some fascinating questions
within the evolution of the of mushrooms
so there are lots and lots of kinds of
mushrooms that don't release their
spores into the air so the way that a
mushroom with gills works is to the
spores actually jump off the Gill
surfaces and they fall between the
little spaces between gills and then
they're Swept Away by air currents but
there's a lot and lots of different
mechanisms that mushrooms use
alternative mechanisms that mushrooms
use to disperse their spores so there
are stink horns
that create these awful smells that
attract insects carry on flies for
example that eat the spores and then
carry them and disperse them in when
they when they
defecate there are
puffballs who spores a shot into the air
when the fruit bodies compressed by
raindrops
there's all kinds of other mechanisms
out there what's not clear is is why
these different and truffles too
truffles that some truffles tend to call
them false truffles that are mushrooms
that remain below ground and they're
they're dispersed by animals that dig
for them and then consume the
the Truffle
um
this is a process that's evolved many
many times at least 80 different times
in the evolution of the whole
mushroom diversity of mushrooms and it's
not clear why this happened small
release involving
wind is is such an efficient mechanism
for for dispersing sport those are
really interesting questions there about
how and excuse me why and then how these
different mechanisms actually evolved
and unfortunately this has been so much
Extinction that's occurred during the
history of the mushrooms that we're left
with these sort of bizarre mechanisms of
sport dispersal and we have no idea
about the how they evolved and so
there's some really interesting
questions there that interests me
because I'm interested in the way that
spores work
um what else what else all kinds of
interesting questions about
about the fungi their interactions with
the human body when we talked about
those I mean how is it that they really
do how is it that they actually act in a
beneficial fashion
are they you know just benign and they
don't have a positive effect on the body
or if not what are the positive effects
of the fungi that grow in the gut
through these interactions with bacteria
and also on their own
so there's this
many many questions about the fungi I
mean we've touched on some of them here
in our conversation about why fungi In
the End Produce
these psychoactive compounds actually
having some real answers to that
question would be fascinating and
looking at interactions between fungi
and insects
I think will be fascinating
um
lots and lots of other questions and we
don't have time for it but there's lots
of work on mycorrhizal fungi so mushroom
fungi and others that interact with
most plants and forest trees in
particular that's really interesting
areas of research there on the
that mutualistic symbiosis between fungi
and the roots of forest trees
so yeah this this there are lots of
opportunities
four interesting research on fungi
for sure yeah and um I would recommend
to my viewers if they're interested so
firstly reads the book mushroom because
I think it's a fascinating and great
overview of the many different areas
that we've touched upon but I know that
you've also written many other books and
so I thought I'd just give you the
chance to sort of give a bit of a a
quick summary of some of the other books
that you've written
um because they've touched by three
different topics
well I'd just say for the the there is a
sort of almost more popular version of
the book that you read the the
um mushroom book that sits out in
paperback now so mushrooms are natural
and cultural history and it's lavishly
Illustrated too for for people to have a
short attention span no it's brilliant
look at the pictures so so that that's a
book but I've actually written other
books too that um the books that are
read most widely actually are part of
the um
Oxford University press series called
very short introductions so I wrote the
very short introduction to fungi it's 30
000 words best introduction to fungal
biology available to humanity
I also wrote the one on microbiology
which is probably due for an update now
but that's also a short short book
um and then probably the most
controversial thing that I've written I
wrote a book called The Selfish ape
which is about us
with um reaction books in in London and
um
so there's almost no mention of fungi in
that book
but that's about
um our inevitable Extinction so that
would be
a subject for a different
non-micological interview but um I'm
actually working on a book now on fungal
medicine so about these interactions
okay I mean the human body and um fungal
fungal biology fungal biology and human
biology yeah so don't really have a
title for that yet but that's a
that's an interesting and a big project
yeah for sure yeah because I was
actually about to ask you like what is
next and so clearly this book is on the
horizon
yeah I think that yeah looking at
the biomedical aspects of our
interactions with the fungi is
is one of my goals and uh
yeah
yeah cool and so I always like to sort
of end the interviews with asking for
like advice not just um for like I guess
in this case specifically about
consumers and uh advice on mushrooms but
more for Life students as well who were
interested in like the sort of career
path that you followed is there any sort
of
um advice that you would want to give to
other students
yeah it's
um advice for students the most
important thing for so for an
undergraduate that's actually thinking
of embarking on a an advanced degree
I this is my my advice to my students
here I work at Miami University which is
in Oxford Ohio and the advice I have for
students here is to pick
an advisor rather than a university
so there's obviously a lot of there's a
premium upon attending a
you know one of the flagship
universities in this this country but I
think a student can often do as well or
better by just picking a really good
advisor so that often actually means a
younger advisor some somebody that's
really
um
early in their career path they're very
eager to work with students and
passionate about their own area of of
research and a professor of that kind
you know the old professor of that kind
those professors might work in any any
number of universities you know whose
names are not as well known as the the
Ivy League schools in this this country
but I think an ambitious an ambitious
student can do really well working with
an advisor that's really committed to to
their research and so find somebody
that's who's research you find really
interesting
that's certainly what I did as a student
and
and what
let entropy be your guide I don't know
that's uh
I mean embarking on a graduate degree in
a field that doesn't really interest you
but no nobody would possibly do that I'm
sure but finding something that really
turns you on I think is is critical
and so
I think yeah I think that's good advice
and for anyone listening who's
interested in I guess learning more
about fungal um biology where can they
find out more about your research and
like my redirects my viewers
um so I've got a website the Mycologist
there's only one the mycologist.com and
so there's a list of books there and
I've got a Blog that I I plop an essay
essay on there from time to time but
yeah that will be the source and anybody
that lot would like to
contact me can do so through the website
okay great I'll put a link to that in
the description so thank you again Nick
for coming on today it's been I feel
like we've done a massive overview
um on all things funky so that's one
great and hope you've had um a fun time
too yes thank you it was a fascinating
conversation and uh as you said very
Broad
-ranging if you ever have me back I'd
likely but you go hand me back we talk
about one thing we'll talk about one
membrane protein in that found in
filamentous fungi and that we could we
could fill out an hour with that I'm
sure that'd be super for sure
very good great thank you so I hope
you've learned something in this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening